Let's discuss the statistical
approaches in more details.
Statistical approaches use the captured
sensor data as training data,
to build up a model of normal behavior.
The earliest approaches used
univariate models, where each metric,
or measure,
such as a CPU utilization of a program,
was treated as an independent,
random variable.
However, this was to crude to
effectively detect intrusions.
The later approaches
use multivariate models
to consider the correlations
between the measures.
For example, CPU utilization and
memory size of the program
are considered together.
Some later approaches also use time
series models to consider the order and
time we can observe events.
For example,
user logging into a workstation and
an email from the workstation are two
events that consider in a time order.
The main advantages of
statistical approaches are that
they are relatively simple,
easy to compute and
they don't have to make a lot of
assumptions about the behavior.
These approaches don't rely on
assumptions about the expected or
normal behaviors, and
they're simple and efficient.
On the other hand, the effectiveness
of these approaches rely on selecting
the right set of measures,
which is a very difficult task.
In addition,
they have complex behaviors that are
beyond the capabilities of these models.